mesdames messieurs chers amis
génovéfains notre pays
comme bon nombre d'autres travers la
planète est confrontée à la propagation
du virus covit 19
lundi dernier le président de la
république a appelé à la responsabilité
collective des unes et des autres en
nous demandant de limiter au strict
nécessaire nos déplacements de façon à
limiter la propagation du virus
aujourd'hui cette consigne même si elle
est observée par le plus grand nombre
et fort heureusement n'est pas respectée
par certains de nos habitants j'appelle
véritablement au respect de ces
consignes strictes de limitations des
déplacements
c'est important pour notre propre santé
mais également pour la santé des autres
c'est collectivement mais au travers de
nos comportements individuels que nous
arriverons à limiter la propagation du
virus et faire en sorte aussi que nos
personnels soignants dans les hôpitaux
puissent se consacrer uniquement à
celles et ceux dont l'état de santé
nécessite la mobilisation pleine et
entière du corps soignant c'est
important je vous demande une nouvelle
fois de respecter ces dispositions du
côté de la ville depuis lundi nous avons
respecté ces règles de confinement pour
la très grande majorité de nos
personnels toutefois il nous faut
assurer dans cette en particulier un
service public essentiel et je pense
notamment en direction des personnes
retraitées je pense notamment en
direction des personnes fragiles c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
maintenu les services de soins à
domicile que nous avons maintenu et
développé les services de portage à
domicile pour les personnels
retraités et les personnels fragile les
services sont mobilisés alarme ou nous
sommes adaptés nous travaillons au moyen
des nouvelles technologies en
développement le télétravail nous avons
toutefois des astreintes technique
voilà qui nécessite la mobilisation sur
le terrain et je pense notamment voilà
aux missions de propreté salubrité
publique
je pense notamment à la mobilisation de
notre police municipale aux côtés de la
police nationale va pour faire respecter
les règles de déplacement et leur
limitation
alors toutefois la police ne pourra pas
tout et j'en appelle une nouvelle fois à
la responsabilité individuelle de
chacune et chacun ce qui nous est
demandé c'est relativement simple c'est
de rester chez nous c'est simple rester
chez nous de façon à limiter les
contacts entre les uns et les autres et
limiter la propagation du virus
covin 19 pour la mobilisation des
services nous avons également fait
distribuer chez les commerçants les
autorisations de sortie pour celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas d'imprimante ou la
possibilité de pouvoir imprimer ces
autorisations chez eux
nous avons au travers de la police
municipale fait distribuer de l'ensemble
des commerçants a ouvert aujourd'hui ben
voilà c'est ces autorisations
nous avons aussi et je remercie le
personnel qui
il est confiné chez lui nous avons
souhaité pouvoir avoir une attention et
appeler une personne retraitée pas pour
nous assurer que tout va bien pour elle
et leur dire la disponibilité de la vive
si toutefois il y avait des besoins
spécifiques
nous avons aussi pris l'initiative de
nous rapprocher des commerçants des
indépendants qui ont été contraints de
fermer leur commerce et de cesser leurs
activités de façon à voir si la ville
pouvait leur être utile dans les
démarches qu'ils ont à accomplir en
direction notamment voilà de tout
tous les organismes aujourd'hui je pense
notamment à tout ce qui concerne leurs
salariés qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent
sans activité dans les prochains jours
nous apporteront aussi une aide en
direction des familles puisque vous le
savez il ya une continuité pédagogique
voulue par l'éducation nationale et j'ai
été sollicité par certaines familles qui
ont des difficultés à pouvoir
accompagner leurs enfants pour faire
leurs devoirs
nous allons
réfléchir et travailler pour mobiliser
je pense notamment à celles et ceux qui
font le soutien scolaire en cas de saint
john academy mais également pourquoi pas
appeler la de nouvelles solidarités
je pense notamment à certains
enseignants retraités qui par le biais
du réseau sociaux par le biais du
numérique là pour apporter solidarité
vis-à-vis de ces familles cette
situation elle doit appeler de nouvelles
solidarités je vous invite à me
contacter si vous avez connaissance de
situations particulières pour lesquels
les services publics pour lesquels la
ville pourrait apporter une contribution
en attendant je réitère mon appel au
respect des règles de limitation des
déplacements aux simples besoins
essentiels je vous remercie de votre
attention et vous retrouverez
régulièrement sur le site internet de la
ville mais également sur le facebook de
la ville des informations importantes
liées aux nouvelles dispositions prises
par l'état dans le cadre de cette
situation tout à fait exceptionnelle